So where we left off I was
attempting to give you the
intuition of divergence and
then I ran out of time.
But anyway, I had defined this
fairly straightforward vector
field that tells us the
velocity of particles in a
fluid at any given point.
And let me clean it
up a little bit.
This one half I had all
these scratch offs.
The velocity, I'm just going to
rewrite it, is equal to 1/2xi.
So at any given point
has no y component.
So all of the velocity is only
in the x direction -- there is
no upwards movement
in the xy plane.
And I was drawing it out.
I said OK, when x is equal
to 1, the magnitude of the
velocity is 1/2 maybe meters
per second, if that's our unit.
When x is equal to 2, the
velocity to the right will
be 1 meter per second,
right -- 1/2 times 2.
So the further we go to the
right, or the more we go to the
right, the faster the particles
are moving to the right.
So now let's try to get
our handle on what
divergence means.
So first of all, let's
take that the divergence
of this function.
So that divergence of v, of our
velocity vector field -- you
could also view that if you
want to abuse some notation,
is our del vector, dot v.
But if we only have one
dimension, so it's the
partial derivative of the x
magnitude with respect to x.
So what's the
partial derivative?
So it's equal to the
partial derivative with
respect to x, of 1/2x.
So it's equal to -- well the
derivative of this with respect
to x is just equal to 1/2 .
So that divergence of
this vector field at
any point is 1/2.
Now what does that tell us?
Well, if you just look at the
definition, right, we
essentially just took the --
how much does the magnitude
of the field increase
in the x direction?
And we see it visually.
As we go, increase in the x
direction, the field gets
stronger and stronger.
Or since we know that this is
the velocity of particles, as
we go in the x direction, the
particles go faster and
faster to the right.
Now what this tells us, what
this positive divergence tells
us is if we were to take
-- let's just take an
arbitrarily small circle.
I think it'll start to make
sense once I draw the circle.
If I take an arbitrarily -- I'm
going to draw it in a different
color -- and this circle could
be arbitrarily small, but I'm
drawing it pretty large so
it can include some of our
vectors that I've drawn.
What's happening?
On the right hand side, I have
particles exiting really,
really fast, right?
And let's say in a given amount
of time, let's say in one
second, in one second out of
the right side, since the
particles are moving really
fast, I'm going to have a
bunch of particles leave
the right hand side, right?
And in the same amount of time,
I will have some particles
come in through the left hand
side, but it's going to be a
fewer number of particles.
So the way you could think
about it is in any given amount
of time, what's happening?
In this space, I have a few
particles entering in through
the left, and I have a much
larger number of particle
leaving through the right.
So what's going to
happen in this space?
It's going to become
less dense, right?
Because in that space is going
to be fewer particles after
a certain amount of time.
More are leaving
than are coming in.
So this positive divergence
tells us that at that point, or
really at any point in this
vector field since the
divergence is 1/2 everywhere,
at any point in this vector
field, the field is
becoming less dense.
Or you could say that more
is flowing out of any
point than flowing in.
It makes sense, right?
Because if as we move to the
right, and it kind of gets
funky if you go into the other
quadrant, so we'll stick to the
first quadrant while we're
trying to get our intuition.
But it makes sense, because
as we move to the right
our particles are getting
faster and faster.
And that kind of just falls out
of the fact that our derivative
with respect to x is positive.
The slope of how much
our x component is
increasing is positive.
So as we go to the right, our
velocities are going getting
faster and faster, which means
if we were to draw a circle
anywhere, we're always going to
have more exiting the right
than entering through the left.
So we're going to be getting
less dense at any given point.
Or you could almost view it as
any given point is almost a
source of particles, or if you
have a sphere, more particles
are going to be coming out of
the sphere through the right,
than coming in through
the sphere to the left.
So you could view a positive
divergence as you could kind of
say well, the field is becoming
less dense at that point, or
the point is a source of the
field, or it's a source of
particles, depending on what
model you want to use.
Now, with that said, let's
take the opposite situation.
Let's say that the vector
field is equal to is
minus 1/2x times i.
And so the divergence -- I'll
use this notation -- the
divergence of our vector field
is just a partial derivative
with respect to x, which
is just minus 1/2.
If I were to graph it
-- this is my y-axis,
this is my x-axis.
So here at like, say, the
point 1, my velocity is
going to be the left 1/2.
At the point 2, my velocity
is going to be the left
1 meter per second.
At the velocity 3,
it's going to be 3/2.
You know it doesn't
depend on y.
It only depends on x.
So now let's draw a
little circle and see
what's happening.
Let's draw it here.
It could be anywhere.
It's infinitely small,
but we're just trying
to get some intuition.
So after a certain amount
of time what's happening?
Let's say after a second.
Well, I'm having a few
particles leave through the
left hand side, right, but I
have many more particles
entering this little region
that I've defined, this little
circle, I'm having many more
particles enter through the
right in a given
amount of time.
So in any given amount of time,
in my defined space, it's going
to get denser and denser.
There's going to be more
and more particles in
that space over time.
So it's getting denser or you
could almost view it as this
space is sucking up particles.
In the previous example it was
a source of particles -- more
were coming out than going in.
Now more going in through
the right than coming out.
And that's what a
negative divergence.
You could almost say --
let's think about the
word, divergence.
When it's positive, if I have
a positive divergence, the
particles or the field is
diverting out of that point.
If I have a negative
divergence -- maybe
let's define a new term.
I've never actually heard it
this way, but maybe a negative
divergence we view as
a convergence, right?
Converge is the
opposite of diverge.
So here, even though some
particles are leaving through
the left, many more particles
are coming through the
right, so it's getting
denser and denser.
And that's this example here.
And actually at every point
in this field we have
a negative divergence.
So every point is getting
denser and denser actually
everywhere in this field.
And then the classic example of
a divergence, although I wanted
to show you that what matters
is the net that's coming
in to a certain area.
But the classic example of a
divergence is a field that
looks something like this.
Where maybe that's the x --
that's the y, this is the x.
If you have a field that looks
something like this, this is
the classical example of a
negative divergence, right?
Where from every direction
you have particles entering,
nothing's leaving.
So obviously, in any given
amount of time, that point is
getting more and more dense.
And the classic example of a
positive divergence is a point
where from every direction
things are leaving it.
So clearly this area is
going to become less dense.
If we're talking about velocity
of particles, after any moment
in time, more particles are
leaving than coming in because
no particles are coming in.
Now what does it mean if
we have a 0 divergence?
So let's try to create a vector
field that has a 0 divergence.
And we'll just stay at
a one-dimension just
for the intuition.
So that means that the
partial derivative with
respect to x is 0.
So let's say my
vector field is 5i.
So the magnitude is always
5 in the i direction.
So let me draw that.
Vector field is always 5.
Another way to think of it
if you have a constant
vector field.
So the magnitude of the
vectors, no matter what
my value of x, is always
going to be the same.
It's always going to be 5.
So if I were to draw a region,
what's happening here?
Are more particles
entering than leaving or
leaving than entering?
No.
For any amount that's coming
in, an equal amount are coming
out in a certain amount of
time, if we use velocity
as our example.
So when you have a divergence
of 0, that means that that part
of the field is not becoming
any more or less dense.
And you could have done it
-- let me show you another.
If my function was, let's
say it equals 2i plus 2j.
It's still a constant, right?
So this velocity field or
vector field will look
something like this.
All the points would
be, the vectors would
have a slope of 1.
But I just wanted you to see
something in two dimensions.
I'll do a fancier example
in the next video.
But even here, if I were to
draw some region, the same
amount is entering as exiting.
So it's not getting any
denser at any point.
And that makes sense because
the divergence of this vector
field -- well, both of them
actually, the divergence
of that vector field.
The partial derivative
of 2 with respect to
x, well that's 0.
Plus the partial derivative
of 2 with respect to y.
Well, that's also 0.
Anyway, I've run
out of time again.
I will see you in
the next video.